The Foundation is a threat to me.
♪♪
(Roaring)
(Screaming)
♪♪
Gaal:
Close your eyes.
Listen to my words.
♪♪
(Unintelligible speaking)
Gaal:
.... foundation.
And dream.
(Bells ringing)
♪♪
I want to tell you something.
Gaal:
A long time ago...a man showed
me how to predict the future.
Gaal:
Our foundation to save humanity
was born.
♪♪
Brother Day:
In my empire there’s a natural
order.
(Crowd cheering)
The Foundation is a threat to
me.
Brother Day:
We will destroy them all.
If there’s war, we shall win.
Hmm.
♪♪
(Ships firing lasers)
Woo!
Tellem:
Gaal Dornick you’ve got a very
special mind.
People would follow you, lead
them.
♪♪
We will be ready to fight Empire
together.
♪♪
I have faith in foundation
The foundation is a cult.
♪♪
(Roaring)
(Screaming)
The foundation can survive this
crisis,...
♪♪
...but...it requires belief.